675 days of reporting speculation all
kinds of stories in there the special
counsels probe is finally over our
political panel is here to react
Republican strategist Holly Turner host
of the Michael no show Michael Pablo
Knowles and Democratic strategist Kevin
Chavis good to see you all good to see
what we're seeing this morning is that
Democrats are the dog who caught the car
the the great conservative consolation
is that eventually reality reasserts
itself we have been told for two years
watch Muller we're gonna get the Muller
report it's Muller time Trump colluded
with Russia
well eventually you have to answer for
all of those predictions none of that
came true and so we we see the reality
the question that we have to ask now is
on the Democrat side of this how did we
get this dossier how did we get this
whole investigation the real
investigation begins now of Democrats
but for President Trump he has been
totally vindicated on this front and so
the left is left either as the cynics
who say okay let's look at the Southern
District okay that's look at stormy
Daniels or they remain conspiracy
theorists who say there is some new
boris and natasha waiting but there is
not it's over Michael have Democrats
overstepped again on this issue going
into a presidential election because
they've made it such a key part of their
messaging against President Trump
it was always bound for failure so it
was always a bad idea for them to invest
all of their hopes into this Russia hoax
narrative now they're calling for
transparency what else can they call for
everybody wants transparency the
president has called for transparency
but I think transparency might end up
hurting him because today we're
celebrating that a two-year witch-hunt
to overturn a presidential election has
failed tomorrow once the celebrations
are over we should be indignant that
this witch hunt began in the first place
that this hoax has been dragged on for
so long in the first place so I want
transparency I don't just want
transparency on the mulder report I
don't just want transparency on anybody
associated with the Muller report I want
to know how this whole charade this
whole farce started in the first place
and I don't think that transparency is
going to reflect very well for Democrats
so the issue is now we're
the goal posts as we always expected at
what we have known for a very long time
that the russia investigation was a hoax
in their moments of candor leftists like
Van Jones for instance who was caught on
that secret camera said Russia is a
nothing burger they pursued it to the
end now Muller is over so all of a
sudden you heard them say no the real
story is in the Southern District of New
York no the real story is a casino that
Trump wanted to build in 1972 or
something
it's those aren't the real stories you
can't switch like that you lose
credibility ultimately Democrats are the
boy who cried wolf it's over we know
that there are no additional indictments
this is a vindication of President Trump
this is a vindication of Republicans the
2016 election I'm sorry we're not going
to overturn it and if they keep focusing
on the 2016 election they're not going
to have any chance in the 2020 election